when the doom claim Valyria the great
freehold fractured into warring cities
and upstart nations right for the taking
how to be swarmed the Dothraki the horse
Lords of the plains who feared only
defeat and Dragons and how the dragons
were all gone under the great Khal temmo
they sacked and burnt every town and
city in their path no army could stand
against them because the Dothraki do not
stand the horselords do not draw up
battle lines or hide behind shield walls
or layer themselves in armor but the
frackie charge their blades a more
scythe and sword are better to call the
infantry ranks without breaking stride
even their archers far from horseback so
that advancing or retreating the arrows
never cease to the Dothraki a man who
does not ride is no man at all without
honor or bride when the city of cool
[ __ ] realized Kyle tamer was coming
they strengthened their walls doubled
their own guards and hired two full
companies of cell swords
the Dothraki were used to glorified
farmers with spears coho would show them
a proper army with mounted and armoured
cavalry to match the Horde zone as an
afterthought the city leaders sent an
envoy to ask to poor to buy unsullied
the slavers had always claimed that the
unsullied were the great Ascari legions
come again few cared the dragon burnt
ruins of old geese were a stark reminder
that the age of the foot soldier was
over then boy had his orders however and
quickly bought 3,000 unsullied for the
long march back for unsullied do not
ride but while they marched Khal temmo
arrived at Kuo [ __ ]
I can imagine how pleased the car was to
finally face a challenge by the end of
the battle crows and wolves feasted on
what remained of quo [ __ ] heavy horse
all the sell swords had fled qohor knew
that the Dothraki would very soon break
through the gates to rape slave and burn
at their pleasure yet the next day Karl
temer woke to find before the gates
three thousand eunuchs in formation
armed with only Spears shields and
spiked helms the unsullied had slipped
past the Karl's Army in the night while
the Dothraki feasted Karl temmo had many
times their number and could easily have
flanked the small force but to the
Dothraki men on foot have fit only to be
ridden down 18 times the horselords
charged an 18 times the unsullied locked
their shields lowered their spears and
held the line against 20,000 off rocky
screamers when the Karl's arch has
rained arrows on them the unsullied
lifted their shields above their heads
until the squall passed and then they
held the line in the end only six
hundred unsullied remain but more than
twelve thousand off rocky lay dead
including Karl tomoow and all his sons
the new car led the survivors past the
city gates where one by one each man cut
off his braid and threw it down before
the feet of the unsullied defeated and
shamed forever since that day the
unsullied fill the ranks of cities and
households wealthy enough or desperate
enough sell swords fight for gold
Knights for glory and off rocky for
blood to a man the unsullied fight only
to obey with the right master over them
imagine how the forces of chaos would
break against their shields the
conquerors the madmen
the usurpers